hello and welcome to the third Twitter
API version 1.1 tutorial video where we
left off I was showing you guys how to
save the information to either a text
file or the same principle it's gonna be
used to a database and but we saw how
much data Twitter actually gives us
based on each tweet so we ran it for I
don't even know maybe a maybe a minute I
don't know how long we ran it for but
not very long and it was already 1.5
megabytes so as you can imagine that
kind of database would grow very fast
now of course we could put it in some
sort of database and maybe use some
compression or something like that but
really the best thing that we can do is
trim away unnecessary data so a lot of
this data we don't even need so let's
say you know you might be interested in
a lot of other things well let's just
say all you really want is a date stamp
and the tweets right maybe that's all
you really care about so I'm gonna show
you guys at least how you could how you
should trim that kind of data down and
hopefully save you some space in your
database so so now the first thing that
we're gonna do is we get the data and
really what we want to do is split up
that data a little bit so that data is
basically the string of that full JSON
now we don't obviously want all that so
what I'm gonna do is say tweet equals
data dot split and what we want to split
it by is if we come down here and we see
here we have the created at and then
right here write text and then you have
the actual tweet itself so what we're
gonna do is we're just gonna say data
dot split and what it will be split by
is a comma and then it's a double quotes
to call this variable text in the JSON
format and then it's a colon and then it
again with an open quotes double quotes
and you can do this because we're
encasing it in single clothes and so
that's where it begins so we can say
split by that and then give us the first
element right in that air like the first
element so not though not give us the
left side but give us the right side of
this split subsequently if we continue I
see let's find where that text over here
and let's see if we can't get there okay
so the end of this tweet occurs at a
closing quote oh no I just lost it
there's like so much data here though
okay right so the end of the the tweet
is a double quote comma double quote
source in double quotes so we can use
that as a pretty safe splitter now just
as a quick aside the reason why we
wouldn't want to do just like a single
comma and then pick that element is the
actual tweet itself can contain a
comment right that's a form of
punctuation that people will use and
again we'll use that in a little bit
here with our quote unquote CSV it'd be
kind of silly to save it with commas so
anyway we'll get there in a second but
then so again we're going to split now
the other side is split by a double
quote comma double quotes source oops
well let's spell it right otherwise that
won't split very well and then we'll
just close that off and then we want
really the left side of that so the
zeroeth element so now we've got the
full tweet in that variable so the next
thing it's situated here the next thing
that we want to do is instead of print
data let's just print the tweet
since the data there's just so much
there we don't really want that massive
thing right so let's just print tweet
now the next thing that we're gonna want
to do is we want to save it just like we
had been but instead we want to save
tweet but generally you really want like
something else besides just the tweet
right so we might want like a timestamp
and you could put like the whole date
stamp in
but UNIX timestamp is probably better in
my opinion so anyway we'll say save this
equals string time time so that just
gives you a UNIX stamp right and then
what we're gonna do is plus and then
here I'm gonna make our separator a
colon colon like double double colons
right and the idea here is again you
wouldn't want to make it a comma because
it's highly likely that someone is going
to include a comma in their tweet and
you wouldn't even want a single colon
because it's really like when someone
does like at and someone's name it's
followed by a colon a lot so double
colon probably the safest way to handle
this and if you really wanted to be safe
like quadruple colons or something but
double colon is good enough plus we'll
do tweet so plus the actual tweet and so
that's the string basically that we were
going to want to save now save file
still going to be open twit
well actually let's make it twit db2 so
it's a brand new one and now we want to
save our what we want to write is
actually save save this right then a new
line and then we want it to close and
that'll be the loop that we're gonna run
through so let's go ahead and save what
we got and let's run it and see if we've
got any errors first of all looks like
we're just printing out tweets now oh
it's so much better than what we were
doing and let me pull it up bring this
over and as we can see it's growing at a
much slower rate that's very nice
so we can open this up edit it with
notepad and now not only have we seen
that now we don't have like those extra
rows just very nice and clean it's just
the tweet we have done very good so
obviously you might want to you know
separate it by other things too you
might want to get the followers
following you might want to get there
some of them will have a geo location
very few accounts are geo enabled I will
just warn you but you can get that to
you
get all kinds of stuff obviously you saw
how much data Twitter gives you in that
little screen so you can use that you
can print out the stream figure out
exactly what you want but this is how
you can split it save some space on your
database size and at the time and then
also the double colon is a decent way to
split it up of course if you're saving
to an actual database you don't have to
worry about that either so hopefully
that was helpful to some of you guys as
always thanks for watching thanks for
the support in the subscriptions and
until next time